es un mes de cambios sin precedentes en
el panorama político de oriente medio el
presidente de donald trump dio la
bienvenida a la casa blanca al primer
ministro israelí benjamín netanyahu y a
los ministros de relaciones exteriores
de emiratos árabes unidos y bahrein un
día que todos los involucrados
calificaron de histórico ya que firmaron
acuerdos para la normalización de los
lazos entre israel y estas dos naciones
son solo el tercer y cuarto estado árabe
en firmar estos acuerdos después de
egipto en 1979 y jordania en 1994
estamos aquí para cambiar el curso de la
historia después de décadas de división
y conflicto marcamos el amanecer de un
nuevo medio oriente
este día es un giro en la historia
presagia un nuevo amanecer de pasos
durante miles de años el pueblo judío ha
rezado por la paz y es por eso que hoy
estamos llenos de una gratitud tan
profunda
trump dijo que bajo estos acuerdos estos
tres países establecerán embajadas
intercambiarán diplomáticos y cooperarán
en una amplia gama de temas incluidos el
comercio y la seguridad unirlos también
marca un realineamiento regional
estratégico contra irán sin embargo
estos pactos se firmaron sin una
resolución sobre la disputa de larga
data de israel con los palestinos pese a
esto el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de los emiratos árabes unidos
agradeció israel por suspender la
anexión planeada del territorio
palestino según acordaron ambas naciones
el mes pasado a cambio de la
normalización la decisión esta es una
decisión que refuerza lo que compartimos
para lograr un futuro mejor para las
generaciones venideras generations'
stockham no está claro como el plan de
paz de washington para oriente medio
procederá sin la cooperación de la
autoridad palestina que interpreta estos
acuerdos como una traición de la
posición panárabe que exige que israel
se retire de la ocupada cisjordania y
acepte a palestina como estado